THANK YOU.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
I'M BRET BAIER IN
WASHINGTON.
MAJOR NEWS ON TWO DISPUTED
MIDTERM ELECTION BATTLES.
MOMENTS AGO DEMOCRAT STACEY
ABRAMS ENDED HER CAMPAIGN
AND SAID SHE CANNOT WIN BUT
STILL WOULDN'T CALL IT A
CONCESSION SPEECH.
HER HARD FOUGHT EFFORT TO
OVERTAKE REPUBLICAN BRIAN
KEMP IN THE GEORGIA'S
GOVERNOR'S RACE.
IN FIERY REMARKS ABRAMS
CLAIMED DEMOCRACY FAILED
GEORGIA BUT ADDED SHE WILL
NO LONGER STAND IN THE WAY
OF OFFICIALS CERTIFYING KEMP
AS THE WINNER.
MEANTIME IN FLORIDA, THEY
ARE DOING IT THE OLD
FASHIONED WAY TONIGHT.
A HAND RECOUNT OF VOTES
UNDERWAY TO FIND OUT WHO WON
THE U.S. SENATE RACE IN THE
STATE.
WHILE THE GOVERNOR'S RACE
APPEARS OVER AFTER A MACHINE
COUNT AND WILL BE OFFICIALLY
CERTIFIED NEXT WEEK.
REPUBLICAN RON DESANTIS HAS
DECLARED VICTORY FOR THE
SECOND TIME.
THE DEMOCRAT IN THAT RACE,
ANDREW GILLUM RETRACTED HIS
CONCESSION EARLIER THIS WEEK
AND HAS NOT CONCEDED AGAIN
VOWING AS OF A COUPLE HOURS
AGO TO FIGHT ON.
WE HAVE FOX TEAM COVERAGE
PETER DOOCY AT THE BROWARD
COUNTY ELECTION HEADQUARTERS
AGAIN TONIGHT WITH THE
FLORIDA STORY BUT WE START
OFF WITH THE BREAKING NEWS
STEVE HARRIGAN IN ATLANTA
WITH THE VERY CONFUSING
MESSAGE FROM STACEY ABRAMS.
GOOD EVENING.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT THIS WAS A
FIERY ANGRY SPEECH BY ABRAMS
AND PUZZLING AS WELL.
SHE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT SHE
LOST THE GOVERNOR'S RACE IN
GEORGIA TO BRIAN KEMP.
KEMP GOT 50.2% OF THE VOTE.
HE HAD A LEAD OF ABOUT
50,000 VOTES OUT OF
4 MILLION CAST.
SO KEMP REALLY JUST MANAGED
TO AVOID A RUN OFF ELECTION
HE HAD DIPPED UNDER 50% THAT
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED NEXT
MONTH.
HE AVOIDED THAT ABRAMS
TRIED TO GATHER AND PROVE
SHE HAD 17,000 MORE VOTES
COMING.
SHE WAS UNABLE TO DO IT.
SO SHE GIVES HER CONCESSION
SPEECH AND AT THE SAME TIME
SAYS IT'S NOT REALLY A
CONCESSION.
HERE'S ABRAMS.
>> WATCH AN ELECTION
OFFICIAL WHO CLAIMED TO
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE IN THE
STATE BALDLY HOAX FOR
ELECTION ON THE SUPPRESSION
OF THE PEOPLE DEMOCRAT'S
RIGHT TO VOTE HAS BEEN TRULY
APPALLING.
SO, LET'S BE CLEAR, THIS IS
NOT A SPEECH OF CONCESSION.
>> IT CERTAINLY DIDN'T SOUND
LIKE A TYPICAL CONCESSION
SPEECH EITHER.
ABRAMS SAID IN A CONCESSION
SPEECH YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
SAY NICE THINGS ABOUT THE
RACE AND THE OTHER
CANDIDATE.
SHE WAS HAVING NONE OF THAT
SHE SAID THE DEMOCRACY HAD
FAILED THE VOTERS IN
GEORGIA.
THERE WAS VOTER SUPPRESSION
ACROSS THE STATE AND BLAMED
BRIAN KEMP WHO WAS THE CHIEF
ELECTION OFFICER, THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
SHE SAID HE RAN A VICIOUS
CAMPAIGN.
AS FOR KEMP HIMSELF, WHO HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH TRANSITION
OFFICIALS, EARLIER HE SAID
ABRAMS WAS HAVING TEMPER
TANTRUMS BUT HIS TONE HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY AFTER
THIS PRESS CONFERENCE BY
ABRAMS.
KEMP ISSUED THE FOLLOWING
STATEMENT.
I APPRECIATE HER PASSION,
HARD WORK AND COMMITMENT TO
PUBLIC SERVICE.
SO WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW IS
REALLY A BITTER END TO A
BITTER FIGHT IN A REALLY
CLOSELY CONTESTED CONTEST IN
GEORGIA.
ABRAMS JUST 44 YEARS OLD
WILL NOW BE A PRIVATE
CITIZEN BUT WE COULD LIKELY
SEE HER IN FUTURE RACES FOR
GOVERNOR OR SENATOR IN
GEORGIA.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Bret: NO PHONE CALL WE
KNOW OF BETWEEN THE TWO
CAMPAIGNS?
>> ALSO IS LACKING THE
TRADITIONAL PHONE CALL, THE
KEMP TEAM LEARNED ABOUT IT